hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2012 chinese action fantasy movie called
the yin yang master
there is a man named ching ming
he's bred from the human and demon race
which makes him half human and half
demon he works as an officer of the yin
yang bureau guarding demon souls and a
supernatural artifact called the scale
stone
one night there is an attack on the base
and he is alone on the site with all the
guards killed and his senior named simu
also killed
after being accused he gives his
statements that he's not the one that
kills simu because he's the only one
alive at the guarding site his statement
is not accepted so the other guard gives
orders to arrest him disagreeing with
the final choice ching ming uses his
technique to escape from the site
the scene then moves to seven years
later there is a group of yin yang
bureau soldiers running an errand to
deliver some offerings for the festival
on the way they got raided by a
mysterious being the soldiers get scared
and run away but their captain named
voya charges to attack the mysterious
being after a while boya manages to
reveal the identity of the mysterious
being
it turns out that the mysterious being
is disguised by three ferrets using a
costume they then continue to fight but
when they're about to clash someone
casts a spell between them and it causes
a mini explosion
turns out ching ming is the ferret
subordinate and he was the one who cast
the spell
he then immediately casts a spell again
to boya making boya slip every time he
gets up
after that ching ming calls all of his
subordinates to loot the offerings after
they finish the loot they go back to
their hideout there they have a good
rest for themselves
on one night two black winged demons
infiltrate the yin yang bureau palace
one of the demons casts a spell and
controls one of the guards causing the
guard to cause a ruckus inside the
subduing cells where the evil demon is
imprisoned because of this the captain
that guards the scale stone rushes to
the site the demon then continues to
carry out their plan
they kill all of the remaining guards
that are guarding the scale stone when
they're about to leave the yin yang
bureau chief named beni realizes that
the demons have broken into the place
and then she rushes to the site she
immediately casts a spell to seal the
scale stone
unfortunately one of the demons manages
to get the artifact and flies out and
the other demon is trapped inside the
seal after that the chief chases the
demon the chief immediately shoots an
arrow to the demon and it hits the demon
so he falls down into the forest
coincidentally the three ferrets are
also there and they immediately take the
scale stone feeling frightened one of
the ferrets swallows the stone and then
they run from the forest
after they get back they explain to
ching ming that one of them swallows the
stone without knowing what the stone is
when ching ming checks the ferret
suddenly his surroundings turn dark and
the demon king orders ching ming to
resurrect him because ching ming has his
blood running in his veins ching ming
then rushes to lock the ferret with a
spell then immediately goes to the demon
realm to get something connected to the
scale stone
meanwhile the black wing demon goes back
to his hideout to report to his superior
the snow queen demon the snow queen
demon then punishes him by freezing him
and then orders her hand demon to
execute him
the scene continues to boya he is being
summoned to the court of the guard and
give an order to find the offerings that
he lost
boya then travels to get information
about ching ming he also meets someone
named shell who seems to know ching ming
and she tells boya that he might find
ching ming in the demon realm
she also asked voya to bring her to find
ching ming because she knows how to get
to the demon realm
long story short they finally get to the
demon realm entrance shenla starts to
cast a spell to open the entrance and
she manages to do it
inside the demon realm shenla
immediately applies plum leaf water for
both of them to get rid human scents off
them
after that they look around the demon
realm while waiting for ching-ming to
show up after a while ching-ming also
arrives in the demon realm
boyo rushes to him and turns out shanle
is also one of ching-ming subordinates
then ching ming casts a spell on him
again making boya's body in ching ming's
control
ching-ming then goes to the owner of the
fighting pits who knows a lot about
artifacts both of them are business
partners
ching-ming then asks for the tushan
sword tushan sword is an artifact that
defeated the demon king in the past
because of this the tushan sword is a
taboo word in the demon realm
the owner refuses and claims that he
doesn't know about the sword's
whereabouts but then ching ming uses his
techniques to threaten the owner the
owner then suggests that he will give
the sword if ching ming also gives him
something
ching ming trades two human lives which
is boya and shenla to the owner
the owner immediately puts boya to the
fighting pit arena for entertainment
before leaving ching ming casts a
talisman spell and leaves it near the
arena after that he gets to the swords
location
when he manages to unseal the sword
suddenly the yin yang bureau officers
surround him
ching ming who already knows this would
happen manages to escape again by using
his technique but unfortunately the
chief is already waiting for him he then
casts an illusion spell but the chief
knows how to dispel it and she manages
to dispel the illusion after that he
continues to run
meanwhile boya fights with the red evil
demon which he underestimates
he manages to give several punches to
the demon but surprisingly the demon
becomes angry and then transforms to a
bigger size of him this makes the demon
have the upper hand after a while the
demon manages to capture boya
suddenly ching ming's talisman activates
and goes to the demon making him slip if
he takes another step
here voya coincidentally finds the
demon's weak spot he uses this
opportunity to attack the demon and the
demon turns back to his small version
the audience then throws some weapons
for boya to execute the demon boya then
takes an axe but he spares the demon's
life
he then climbs up to free shenla after
that they get cornered by the demon
soldier but surprisingly the red evil
demon also comes up and helps them to
escape
on the other hand ching ming arrives at
the arena and the sword gets snatched by
the chief
he fights back to get the sword but then
the cover explodes and the sword goes
straight to boya's location making the
demon step back they then run outside
and get surrounded by the demon soldier
ching ming then comes to them and
suddenly the yin yang bureau officers
come out and attack them
ching ming immediately casts a
protection spell but an officer manages
to get to his back and attacks him
unexpectedly the chief comes to his aid
and protects him unfortunately the chief
gets attacked by the officers
this makes ching ming very angry and
then he immediately casts a
teleportation spell teleporting them to
his hideout
ching ming treats the chief's wound and
he spots a bracelet attached to her
it turns out that the bracelet is a pact
between the chief and ching ming in the
past
the pact is a sign of the demon that has
a master making the demon can't be
turned evil because he is half human and
half demon he can be both master and
familiar that is why he has many
subordinates that are his familiar after
a while the chief wakes up and then
ching ming explains the real events
about semu that have occurred before
one night simu asks chiang ming for
himself to cover ching ming's shift to
guard the scale stone and ching-ming
agrees
after that ching ming senses the demon
king's aura coming from the scale stone
he immediately rushes to there only to
find out that the guard has been killed
and there is no queen demon with wounded
simus hostages the demon then attacks
ching ming with her spell
ching ming manages to block the attack
but after that they disappear
after all that explanation the chief
still doesn't trust ching ming meanwhile
the ferret has already mutated and he
attacks his surroundings
qingbing realizes that the scale stone
is within the ferret so he decides to
stab him with tishon sword making the
ferret die and turning the ferret to
dust the scale stone is taken by the
chief and she leaves by teleportation
spell
the group then gives a ceremony to the
ferret that died ching ming and the rest
also have some drinks to reminisce about
the ferret
continuing to the chief she teleports to
the forest where the yin yang bureau
officers find her not long after
suddenly the snow queen demon strikes
them with a wide range spell causing
many of the officers to freeze
then the snow queen demon strikes the
remaining officers that survived with
close combat eventually she manages to
kill all the officers except for the
chief when the chief is cornered ching
ming comes and helps the chief from
getting killed the snow queen then
lowers chiang ming out of the area and
they battle each other meanwhile
surprisingly simu is still alive and
comes to the chief's location out of
nowhere he casts a cursed spell to the
chief making the chief pass out and he
then takes the scale stone from the
chief he then fuses with the stone and
becomes the new demon king on the other
hand ching ming eventually won the
battle the snow queen demon then says
her last word and that's when ching ming
realizes simu is the one who tried to
steal the scale stone and made a pact
with her after that he stabs and kills
the snow queen demon
after simu becomes the demon king he
goes to the demon realm
there he casts a spell that causes all
the demons in the demon realm to mutate
after that sumu orders all of the demons
to attack humans
ching ming subordinate acts fast they
apply talisman spells to them to avoid
the mutation then they move to the
bridge the only way that connects human
world and demon realm
at first boyo refuses to join them but
then red evil demon asks him to join and
he agrees
ching ming comes to where semu is
simu then explains that he's the one who
freed the snow queen demon from the
subduing cell and also the one who
attempts to steal the scale stone after
that simu and ching ming fought at first
ching-ming is no match against simu but
then he gives simu a surprise attack
stabbing simu right on the chest
surprisingly the tanchu sword has no
effects on semu
simu then hits ching ming and he passes
out
ching ming subordinate starts a siege to
block the mutated demon soldier
the rat demon tries to bite the bridge
from below to destroy the bridge
one of them also turns into a tree
blocking the only way to pass the bridge
after a while voya shenla and the red
evil demon fall from the tree and have
to fight close combat but suddenly the
demon soldier stops to attack
turns out semu is already there and he
immediately stabs ching ming in front of
his subordinates
after that he drops ching ming off the
bridge the tree demon also turns back to
her human form so they had to fight
close combat but fortunately half part
of the bridge is destroyed by the rat
demons so they immediately try to
destroy the other half
boya who is in the front line attacks
one of the demons and gets blocked the
demon counters boya's attack but the red
evil demon acts fast to carry him so
he's the one getting stabbed right on
his chest
the red evil demon then carries the
demon and jumps to destroy the bridge he
then says goodbye to boya as he falls
from the bridge
meanwhile ching ming meets again with
the demon king in his dying moments
there the demon king shows him the
struggles of his subordinate and offers
him his power but he's the one who must
become the master
ching min refuses as he tries to
self-destruct himself so the demon
king's power will also disappear because
of this the demon king changes the offer
and they finally make a pact together
with ching ming becoming the master
simu then tries to pass the bridge by
his gigantic hand demon but suddenly
simu comes with his new obtained power
the two of them fight again but now
ching ming's the one with the upper hand
the fight goes one-sidedly and
eventually ching-ming punches through
simu's chest and takes the scale stone
from him simu then disappears into the
dust as he disappears the spell cast
upon the chief also lifts out the chief
then immediately comes to the bridge and
asks him to stay with humans but he
refuses he destroys the scale stone and
then he releases all the pact he has
made with all of his subordinates he
then goes back to the demon realm with
all of the demons that survived
in the final scene boya is seen to be a
great hero by the civilians as the cart
moves he talks his hope about the return
of ching ming who actually didn't want
to release all his pack to become the
new demon king but he had two
then boya meets again with shenla as
they both smile at each other
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching